ROMIN IRANI: Hello, everyone.
I'm Romin Irani.
I work as a Developer
Advocate at Google Cloud.
And I'm pleased to bring you
a new episode of "Architecting
with Google Cloud."
Today we are going to be looking
at Ather Energy, a leading
electric vehicle
manufacturer in India,
and specifically, right,
speaking of electric vehicles
and two-wheelers, which
Ather Energy is known for,
when you actually take
the scooter and zoom away,
you would seldom think of
what are the things that
are happening on the scooter
itself, and what kind of data
is flowing into the platform.
And how do they create a unique
experience for their customers?
So I'm pleased to welcome
Ram Bhavaraju, who
heads software and web
technologies at Ather Energy.
Welcome, Ram, to the show.
RAM BHAVARAJU:
Thanks a lot, Romin.
Thanks for having me here.
So my name is Ram Bhavaraju.
I head software and
web technologies here
at Ather Energy, so software
covers the entire length
and breadth of what we do with
data, right, from our factory,
all the way to the customer,
all the applications for people,
the platforms that we maintain.
ROMIN IRANI: Thanks,
Ram, for joining us.
So let's get started with
learning a bit more about Ather
Energy.
And specifically, if you could
tell us some of the unique
features that you
bring to the market.
And since you had a ringside
view of the EV evolution
that's across the
country, could you
share some of your
thoughts on that too?
RAM BHAVARAJU:
I'll start probably
with Ather Energy and
just focusing more on what
we started this journey for.
So we started to get a
very good form factor out
of two-wheeler vehicles.
So we wanted to build
an EV energy ecosystem
and have a great
customer experience
and have a great product
fitment into the market.
And that's how the entire
Ather Energy's product started.
And we truly believe
in customer experience.
And that's where
probably the first
of its kind in a two-wheeler
form factor started at data.
And we had features like
ride statistics, navigation
on a 7-inch touchscreen.
There are lots of
two-wheelers out there
in India, which had
this kind of a screen.
But none of them had
this kind of a form
factor of touchscreen.
And we had navigation, turn by
turn navigation on top of it.
We had ride statistics, where
using your companion app
and also on your
touchscreen on your vehicle.
We have something like your
side stand detection, which
gives you an indication if
your side stand is open when
you're riding your vehicle.
So on and so forth, lots
of these unique features
are probably the first of
its kind in the market.
It's coming from Ather.
And now that the market has been
quite evolving in the last two
or three years,
specifically backed up
by central government
policy called
FAME, fast adoption for both the
hybrid and electric vehicles.
And the latest version
of it was version 2,
which was released in 2020.
That kind of catapulted the
entire demand part of things
for an OEM, right, to
ensure the device is
coming to the fully, into the
main fully of the two-wheeler
segment.
That kind of a demand was
really, really helpful.
And FAME subsidy really helped
us gather lots of momentum.
And that's where lots of
electric vehicles also,
manufacturers also, started
coming into the picture.
ROMIN IRANI: Great.
So, you know, you
mentioned various features
that you've already built,
for example, the side
stand, the ride
characteristics, et cetera.
So I can almost imagine the
kind of data that's continuously
going off every single
vehicle, which you are then
sort of analyzing
and even giving
near-term real feedback
to the customer,
or the driver in this case.
So if you could just give us
a bit of an overview in terms
of the sheer scale
of the data platform
that you would
have to build out,
and how Google Cloud platform
has helped you do that.
RAM BHAVARAJU: That's
a very good question,
to help everyone
understand also what
I said electric vehicle do.
Just look at the form factor
of two-wheelers in this case,
because of obviously
the Ather Energy, right?
We have 50 plus sensors
within our vehicle.
And they keep sending data
at different frequencies
at a large volume.
The frequency at
which they send,
we kind of gather all the data,
and at five second intervals,
and start sending
it into the cloud.
And we have a fleet of 20k+
vehicles out there on the road,
right?
And think about 20k+ vehicles
on the road sending almost
or so 500 or 600 variables
at a five second interval.
It becomes like if I just do
the basic mathematics, it's
gigabytes from each
of these vehicles,
turns into terabytes of
information on a monthly basis.
And our core storage right
now runs in petabytes.
Why do we collect
such volume of data?
It's about because
as I was pointing
towards all the unique
features what we are building.
For example, if I look
at ride statistics,
I need to understand, how
did your ride go, and then
probably present it back to you
as a customer in a way where
you could consume it, because
for an average customer,
average rider in
this case, right?
They would not understand
all the fancy things
happening within the
electric vehicle.
We have to convert all
this data, all this useful,
like all the raw data
into useful information.
And doing this at near real time
had been the biggest challenge.
And that is where we are
kind of trying to solve
all these problems in there.
ROMIN IRANI: Thanks,
Ram, into giving us
an insight in terms
of how the data is
collected and processed.
What I'd like to do next
is to straightaway dive
into the architecture.
So if you could explain
to us like right
from the time a
scooter takes off,
what's the kind of
requests or data
that's flowing in
from the vehicle
into the cloud platform?
What are the
different components
there that you are using on GCP?
And how does this
whole thing come alive?
RAM BHAVARAJU: So
since we started
with this ride statistics
and the entire raw data,
the sheer volume of data, I'll
take those two as an example
and then probably walk you
through the architecture.
Leaving what happens
inside the vehicle,
let's see the data is now
pushed to an MQTT broker, what
we call as an IoT broker,
internet of things broker,
all the way to start publishing
data into this broker.
And this broker then publishes
further up into Kafka cluster.
And this Artemis
broker's main role
is just to send data
from the vehicles all
the way into a
Kafka cluster, where
the majority of the processing
of this huge volume of data
is happening.
And all of these workloads
are currently running on GKE.
Once the data comes
into Kafka, we
have both the worlds, that is
the streaming part of Kafka.
We also use the consumer's
or probably the publisher's
part of the Kafka.
But when we looked at the volume
of data, what is coming in,
right, when I said
about gigabytes,
terabytes, and mostly the
petabytes for cloud storage.
So 70%+ of our use cases
are the raw data itself.
So this is where it
kind of gives you
insights like product
metrics, gives you
insight into diagnostics
of the vehicle,
or probably look at
service and support,
and also a lot into the
research and development
of the vehicle itself.
And because it's so
important for every
of these units to come together,
the raw data processing
is also the quintessential
for us, right?
So that is where we kind of
use these node pools, which
are within the K clusters.
And we use lots of
consumers in that case.
All this data gets processed,
to a certain extent,
and then will get pushed
into Google Cloud Storage.
We use Data Block and
Dataflow to a large extent.
To query this
data, I was talking
about all this internal
use cases of diagnostics
or internal use
cases of R&D research
and development of things.
For that, we use Data
Block and Dataflow.
And we kind of use both these
tools to process the data
and also query the
data to a large extent.
Now, this is the
raw data part of it.
Now, let's look at something
like a ride statistic,
which is about 20%-30%
of the use cases.
This 20%-30% of use cases
are more, what do you say,
are more realistic
in this sense,
because you have to
do real time analysis.
We have to do the real time
processing of this data,
and then push it further
into an upstream,
something like a
real-time database
called Firebase,
where all of our apps
are like reading this data from.
So we have Ather app, Ather
app is like an ownership app,
which the customers would
be able to see the vehicle
information on their app.
This vehicle analytics,
again, requires
lots of streaming of data,
so all these messages
which are coming in, by
the hundreds of thousands,
and runs into billions over
a period of day or two.
All this data gets
processed in near real time
and then gets pushed into
Firebase, which then pushes
that data into the Ather app.
And that's where
the customers are
able to see the ride statistics.
Again, we also use some
amount of batch jobs there.
And that is where we
use data proper Sparks,
streaming what we
produce, and stream
that data using those batches.
ROMIN IRANI: Thanks
for taking us
through the entire
request in terms
of how you're getting the data,
you're further enriching it,
and then the various
applications that are actually
using this data to provide both
near real-time feedback also
to the user.
But the scale that
you mentioned,
right, I just wanted
to bring that up again.
I'm sure there would have
been an instant or two where
probably some things
didn't go right.
So could you maybe
just take our listeners
through maybe an instance
where there was an issue,
and how you overcame that?
RAM BHAVARAJU: Issues
are common, right,
and that's where the software
teams would learn, right?
So we ran into this issue of
exhausting the node pools.
So GKE runs on a concept
of a cluster, which
is made of multiple different
node pools, odd parts what
we call them, a part is
like a single unit which
runs any application per se.
In this case, let's
take an example
of a Kafka consumer,
which is nothing
but an application, which
consumes the data from Kafka
and does some action.
And we ran out of
node pools on GKE,
because GKE is a very good
hybrid of open source,
like using your Kubernetes,
but also has managed services.
The entire control
plane is managed by GCP,
so the Google Cloud platform
itself in this case, right?
The node pools obviously have
this concept of auto-scaling.
So we ran into a place where
one of our major consumers,
and it has a big
work pool load that's
about almost 180 node
pools in that case,
was trying to auto-scale
itself, and it ran out of nodes.
And what happened was that
no one knew, once you run out
of the resources, that is you
exhausted the entire node pool,
you have to wait until
you get any backup.
In this case, what
happened is that we
are in that region within
India where we did not
do multi-zone clusters
at that point in time,
because we wanted a
majority of our workplace
was running on a single
zone at that case rate.
The entire node pool went into
something called a security
mode, because the control
frame thinks that, OK, someone
is trying to scale up way
beyond the node's actual limits.
And now you don't know what to
do with it, because you're not
able to do that.
Then the cluster finds
out, saying that, OK,
I don't have enough resources.
Now I have to fix it, because
I have to allocate the existing
resources itself.
Something like that happened.
And it took about 12 to 14 hours
for us to recover from that.
Luckily, the good
part of that was
that none of the public-facing
node pools were down.
But obviously from
enduring use case,
for anyone to access
as GKE cluster,
we have to go via the control
frame, what we call it
as the Cube CTLD portal, that
is the terminal window where we
log in and look at our
node pools and resources,
so on and so forth.
We weren't able to access it.
But luckily, we had
very good support
from the Google product team
to help us resolve the issue.
Eventually, we found
out that there is a way
to work with the
cluster management
issue via this control
plane to like share
the loads between the zones.
And then we started getting
into that kind of conversations
with the Google platform
support specialists.
And it was just, while it
was already challenging,
because obviously train doors,
US is operating with panic
saying, that, hey, I'm not able
to look at what is happening
in my own production.
But eventually, it's
a good learning curve,
because that's where
we also got lots
of these important things, what
we do on the cloud platform.
ROMIN IRANI: That was an
interesting challenge,
and thanks, Ram, for taking
us into how you addressed it.
What I wanted to do now is
actually go back to the vehicle
itself.
And earlier you
mentioned that there's
a device that's running
on the vehicle itself,
right at the edge.
So if you could tell
us a little bit more
about the features of the device
that is there on the vehicle.
RAM BHAVARAJU: So
vehicle intelligence
as a platform, if we say
put that word across, right?
So we are trying to make
a decision, the vehicle
and the cloud almost
having like similar or more
functionalities.
But there are limitations
in terms of vehicle,
just because of the
hardware limitations,
and also the form factor, what
you can fit within the vehicle.
And that's the very
fact that intelligence
is like a little bit of what
is a compact in that sense.
We have multiple layers
within the vehicle itself.
So we have the dashboard layer,
which is the human machine
interface or a chimney
what we call it,
which has a UI app, which is
built on Android platform.
Then we have applications
which are supporting this HMA,
and also taking lots
of intelligent steps.
So we have data intelligence
as a library or an application,
which runs, which takes
informed decisions around,
I'll give a feature like
auto indicator turn-off.
So auto indicator turn-off
is something which
you would have seen in a car.
And automatically, as soon as
you take it on, it gets back,
the lever pulls back, right?
A similar kind of a thing
in a tubular braking,
and probably you have not
heard or seen about it, right,
so that's one thing as
an intelligent platform,
you're able to build.
Because of these sensors, what
their depth within the vehicle,
we are able to get the data and
auto turn off the indicators.
And these are some
of those features
which the data intelligence
platform is building.
And that's where that data
intelligence as service
which is inside the vehicle.
Then we have a layer called the
networking layer or the edge
device, which is right at
the top of all the layers
within the vehicle, right?
And this is the one which takes
care of your entire connection
to the upstream, that is
your CloudConnect connecting
to the cloud or what
we call it as a V2X,
vehicle to the
cloud in this case.
This is an edge device
oriented application,
which sits right on
the networking layer,
and sends its data to
the Artemis group of what
we spoke about during
the cloud side of things.
It also takes care of one
very, very important or salient
feature, and that's
the reason we call it
as an intelligent or data
intelligence, in this case,
right?
Because we have a 4G
Sim inside the vehicle,
and you are roaming around, and
there's a data connection which
is being there, not there.
And in the situations where the
data connection is not there,
this edge application
starts storing the data
within the vehicle.
And now the challenge
is that how long can it
store, because you're talking
about gigabytes, terabytes,
and petabytes on
the cloud, right?
That's where the
intelligence part of things
comes into the picture.
It can store up to
21 days of data.
Then we also have a very,
very important application
called as a shadow
application, probably a vehicle
and make an application
we call vehicular.
This transforms
all the data, which
is coming from the
internal units,
or the control units within
this electric vehicle,
and sends it to the edge
device or edge application,
and sends its
outputs to the cloud.
It kind of gets all
the data and publishes
to this edge application,
which further publishes up
into the cloud.
Similarly, we also have
a very salient feature
called this feature flag
management system, which
is like a system
which can manage all
the features
outside the vehicle,
like for example, a
customer comes to us,
says that I want to do a
different substitution plan,
or change, add
more features, turn
on more features inside
my vehicle, right?
And that is available right
now at this point in time,
where we will send that
back into the vehicle.
And this vehicle
app is one which
is kind of getting
those commands
and transforming that into those
control units in the language
they understand, or
probably in the command
they would understand.
And so all these layers
are stacked up that way.
You have the edge device which
is sitting right on the edge.
Then you have the dashboard,
which is sitting on the vehicle
and informing the customer,
take some informed decisions.
Then you have this
entire data intelligence,
which is kind of
reading the data,
and making more informed
decisions within the vehicle
and also sending it upwards.
Then the in-vehicle
aboard the shadow,
which is talking
both ways, that is,
to the cloud and from the
cloud, and sending further down
into the different
units within the--
ROMIN IRANI: Thanks,
Ram, for helping
us understand the kind of
intelligence that's built
in every Ather Energy vehicle.
Now, if I just look
at the whole platform
and where you are there right
now in terms of the features,
when you started off, right,
to build out this platform,
there must be certain, I
would say, characteristics,
or certain kind of
features, or the way
you would want this platform to
have turned out in the future.
And what were some of
those technology decisions
that you had to make
at that point in time,
even in terms of the vision
you had for the product?
And how has Google
Cloud platform
helped you achieve that?
RAM BHAVARAJU: Obviously,
the top of the list
is like cutting down
the cost as you scale.
So when you're at 1,000-2,000
vehicles, like a startup,
you would always think about
how do I go fast out there.
But once you start moving
from 2,000, like 10,000,
20,000, and upwards, right?
You have to cut down the cost.
Cost was one of our
major drag things.
And that's where GCP
was very, very helpful.
In fact, the entire
case of GKE is
quite good in terms
of optimize workloads,
like auto-scaling, the
auto-scaling features,
to increase their workloads,
reduce their workloads
on demand.
And something like preemptible
virtual machines or PBMs,
what you call them
as, to be attached
to these workloads, which
inherently saves lots
of cost in that sense, right?
So we were able to balance all
these tools, all these managed
services together.
And one of the key things
about this informed decision
of being data on
Google Cloud Platform
is the kind of awareness around
the open source platform,
and the technologies,
what GCP brings in.
So and we have a blend of very
good open source technologies.
And we also have
enterprise level support
for those technologies.
And that's a good
blend of things, right?
So that's very inherently,
GCP understands
the needs of the customers
to a large extent.
And that's one of the key
things for any company
to take this decision, not
just data, because you'll
have also something called
as a community support.
So you have this expert support
in terms of how to run systems,
and then you have this
community support, too,
how to build systems.
So you need both the
worlds together, right?
So until both the worlds
are like seamlessly working
together, it's very,
very tough to have
that kind of like, what do you
say, a marriage in this case,
right? to run the entire
production systems out there.
And that's it, GCP was
very, very, very helpful.
And that kind of
maturity in terms
of understanding the
open-source platforms
and getting them into the
mainstream of managed services.
So I'll give a very, very
clear example, in this case.
We were looking
at hive metastore,
to be available as a
managed service within GCP.
And luckily, or
probably, Google also
was thinking about
the same thing.
And GCP was really saying,
hey, hive metastore
has now generic availability.
You don't have to go and build
it like a workload within GKE.
We have it as a G, or
generic availability.
It means that we can turn on
the service whenever we want it.
So that gives a
very good example
of how Google helps and listen
to the customers in this case,
and being very
proactive in terms
of understanding those
open source technologies
and bringing them into a
good product treatment.
ROMIN IRANI: Thanks,
Ram, for this.
And this brings us to
the end of this episode.
Thank you, Ram, so much for
joining us on this episode
and sharing your knowledge
about the platform.
RAM BHAVARAJU:
Thanks a lot, Romin.
Thanks a lot for
this opportunity
and really appreciate
your taking your time
and asking me all
these questions.
ROMIN IRANI: Great, so folks,
if you've liked this episode,
click on like as
well as subscribe.
Please do leave us some comments
in terms of any future episodes
that you would like to see.
Thank you so much
for joining us today
on another episode
of "Architecting
with Google Cloud."
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]